okay it seems seems pretty
straightforward from here okay here's
the here's the seven step process number
one impeach Donald Trump step two
Pence's vice is president step three
pence appoints me vice president step
four pence resigns Step five
I'm president step six I impose the
death penalty on everyone who face times
in public or ditches their shopping cart
in the middle of the parking lot step 7
utopia it is that is our path I just I
just laid it out things look pretty
dicey right now but we could be headed
towards really paradise on earth it is
it is within our grasp so that's my plan
anyway
now the whistleblower complaint is as
I'm sure you've heard in the Director of
National Intelligence Joseph Maguire
testifying on Capitol Hill lots of stuff
going on which we're gonna talk about in
just a moment but first a word from
policy genius September is wrapping up
but you know September is also national
life insurance Awareness Month most
people aren't aware of that got to raise
awareness of the fact that it's an
awareness month and in fact most people
there aren't even aware that they need
life insurance it's just not something
they think about
that's why 40% of Americans this is
pretty crazy 40% of Americans don't have
life insurance but getting life
insurance doesn't need to be difficult
or expensive right now prices are the
lowest they've been in 20 years and
policy genius has made it easier than
ever to get covered I know it's not
something we want to think about you
know because when you think about life
insurance it's not necessarily a fun
thing but here's the good news
policy genius they handle all the
paperwork and the red tape they make it
a lot easier for you and policy genus
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home insurance auto insurance disability
insurance if you need life insurance but
you just haven't gotten around to it
or it seems too complicated to tackle
right now national life insurance
Awareness Month is a good time - it's a
good a time as any really to get started
and to get going with that so go to
policy genius.com
get quotes apply in minutes you can do
the whole thing on your phone right now
it's as easy as that policy genius the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance
alright first let's talk about this
whistleblower thing and look one of the
things I hate about these kinds of
stories is that everybody becomes an
expert all right I'm sure you've you've
noticed everyone's an expert everyone
especially talking heads like myself
suddenly act like they have some sort of
relevant expertise that will enable them
to give meaningful insight they say I've
looked at this whistleblower report and
you know according to my experience of
which I have none I admit that I have no
expertise here at all I could only just
read this stuff like you and follow the
news reports and and give you my general
impression for what it's worth which
probably isn't that much so now that
I've told you why my opinion doesn't
matter at all you shouldn't listen to it
I will move on to giving you my opinion
first I think again with this
whistleblower report just like with the
transcript yesterday or the Moller
report or anything else the Democrats
have overplayed their hands
significantly which is a stupid move
politically obviously because it can
overshadow or blunt the impact of
otherwise troubling revelations or
allegations and that's why you don't
hype things up too much beforehand
everybody everybody knows that everyone
should know it so there's a classic
blunder if you really think you've got
something good up your sleeve you don't
need to tell anybody ahead of time like
the other night just as an example I
made some absolutely amazing meatballs
but I didn't tell my family ahead of
time now I knew the meatballs were great
but I didn't say them I didn't tell my
wife my kids oh these are great
meatballs you're gonna love them instead
I just gave him two meatballs and I let
them experience them and be brought to
tears of joy over how great the
meatballs were which is exactly what
happened no exaggeration so yes I am
comparing The Whistleblower report to
meatballs this is the level of
commentary you can expect from this show
I don't even know why you're watching it
now what does the whistleblower
complaint primarily consist of it seems
that it mainly consists of
counting the transcripts we already read
and talking about media reports that
we've already seen the only troubling
part is the part that alleges what could
be if it were true a cover up let me
read from the whistleblower report it
says White House officials told me that
they were directed that's in quotes by
White House lawyers to remove the
electronic transcript from the computer
system transcript of the call between
the Ukrainian president and Trump in
which such credits transcripts are
normally stored for coordination
finalization and distribution to
cabinet-level officials instead the
transcript was loaded into a separate
electronic system that is otherwise used
to store and handle classified
information of an especially sensitive
nature one White House official
described this act as an abuse of this
electronic system because the call did
not contain anything remotely sensitive
from a national security perspective now
and then there's there's a couple other
references to that and the claim here
that's being made is that this is
something White House officials have
done on a number of occasions not just
with the Ukrainian thing but with other
politically sensitive material that they
have put into and they've stored in a
separate server to keep it away from
prying eyes I don't want to get into
cliches about the cover-up is worse than
the crime but well there you go it is
and yes this is third hand anonymous
information this is an anonymous claim
from someone who heard it secondhand so
therefore for us it is third hand so you
take it with whatever amount of salt is
necessary and it probably is a pretty
heaping dose but the claim that a
computer system is being used as a means
to hide politically sensitive material
well the claim is there might not be
true but it's there it's in the report
so now it's gonna be investigated and I
have no doubt we're gonna hear more
about this and it will become maybe the
key point in impeachment as we move
forward but at any rate that as far as I
can tell is really the only relevant
part of the complaint the rest of it
restates what we already read either in
the whistle in the trip the transcript
or and other media reports that should
be something if you if you really
want this whistleblower report to be
true and to be and to be an actual
documentation of criminal activity now
it's sad that so many people do want
that they want the president to have
committed a crime and that's a totally
separate discussion but if you do want
that it should trouble you that there
are so many references to media reports
why would a whistleblower need to
reference things that were in the hill
comm but Democrats aren't focused enough
to home in on this aspect of it instead
we get well in fact let's watch Adam
Schiff in his opening statement before
the DA's testimony this morning I think
he this is this is pretty remarkable
watch this and so what happened on that
call
zalinsky begins by ingratiating himself
and he tries to enlist the support of
the president he expresses his interest
in meeting with the President and says
his country wants to acquire more
weapons from us to defend itself and
what is the president's response well it
reads like a classic organized crime
shakedown we've been very good to your
country very good no other country has
done as much as we have but you know
what I don't see much reciprocity here I
hear what you want I have a favor I want
from you though and I'm going to say
this only 7 times so you better listen
good I want you to make up dirt on my
political opponent understand lots of it
on this and on that I'm gonna put you in
touch with people and not just any
people I'm gonna put you in touch with
Attorney General the United States my
attorney general bill Barr he's got the
whole weight of the American law
enforcement behind him and I'm gonna put
you in touch with Rudy you're gonna love
him trust me you know what I'm asking
and so I'm only gonna say this a few
more times in a few more ways
and by the way don't call me again I'll
call you when you've done what I asked
this is in sum and character what the
president was trying to communicate with
the president of Ukraine it would be
funny if it wasn't such a graphic
betrayal of the president's oath of
office so you see what he just just did
there right
he gave a fictional retelling of the
transcript that lengthy quote that he
offered was not real that's not actually
what was in the transcript he made that
up I started my show yesterday as a joke
making up a trump transcript a damming
Trump transcript was a joke Adam Schiff
in this was supposed to be a very
important hearing nationally tell us he
actually did it he just make up his own
transcript which is which is pretty
jaw-dropping and I'm sure it will have
the desired effect for some viewers
pretty straightforward really it's he
did that because he knows that a lot of
ignorant people watching are going to
have not done their own research not
have read the transcript themselves and
they're gonna reach hear that and
they're gonna say oh my gosh this really
is damning I can't believe you said all
that instead of talking about the
scandal them cell itself this is this is
what this is what shift wants to talk
about but it also gives Republicans a
very valid deflection which is why I
think it's a politically stupid move
because now Republicans can talk about
this outrageous dishonest spectacle from
Adams shift Adam Schiff rather than
talking about the hearing itself so
again the only thing that really stands
out is that bit about the politically
sensitive documents being stashed
somewhere on an NSC a computer server
but third hand anonymous claims are a
problem and we've seen enough of them
and we've seen enough of them not pan
out to be very very skeptical of them
maybe the White House does have a file
somewhere where they put records of all
the stupid things Trump says in phone
calls that wouldn't really surprise me
it also wouldn't necessarily be criminal
but I don't know and just reading that
written in a document anonymously is not
enough not enough to assume that it's
true and if we've learned nothing from
the last three years we should have at
least learned that something else I
wanted to say here over the because
there's there's a separate issue related
to this that's been on my mind
over the last week there have been a lot
of videos floating around online you've
probably seen some of them comparing
what various prominent politicians are
saying now about impeachment to what
they said about impeachment in 1998 now
surprisingly the Democrats who are very
much in favor of impeachment in 2019
we're very much against it in 1998 and
then you can also find quotes from
Republicans who were we're all about it
in 1998 and now we're saying that it's a
it's it's a terrible thing to do here's
just this one I think is probably the
most striking here's here's one example
of those videos featuring the lovely
Nancy Pelosi today the Republican
majority is not judging the present
president with fairness but impeaching
him with a vengeance in the
investigation of the President
fundamental principles which Americans
hold dear privacy fairness checks and
balances have been seriously violated
and why because we are here as we are
here today because the Republicans in
the House are paralyzed with hatred of
President Clinton and until the
Republicans free themselves of this
hatred our country will suffer I rise to
one to oppose these unfair motions which
call for the removal of the President of
the United States from office the
Independent Counsel knew that the
president was exonerated when travelgate
whitewater and filegate this was not
fair indeed it is the responsibility of
any prosecutor to immediately reduce we
release information that is exculpatory
for today I'm announcing the House of
Representatives moving forward with
official impeachment inquiry I'm
directing our six committees to proceed
with their investigations under that
umbrella I thank our Chairman chairman
chairman Adler chairmanship of the
chairman Cummings congresswoman Maxine
Waters thank you so what what jumps out
at you about that I'll tell you what
jumps out at me when I see videos like
that it's that these people have been in
power for way way way too long that's
that's the thing that I noticed it's all
the same players I also saw a there was
another video I saw this morning I won't
play it because my gonna play all the
videos but Nadler there's another video
of him when 20 years ago when he was
looked to be about 300 pounds heavier
and he was talking about what a you know
how impeachment is easy racing an
election and it's an attack on the
voters it's all the same people it's all
the same characters still in there so if
we take nothing else from this we should
take the need for maybe term limits that
20 years have passed between this
impeachment scandal and the last one and
it's all the same people saying the same
things
well not the same things really opposite
things from what they said before that
that is that's sad and that's not how a
democracy is supposed to work all right
um
let's move on to two here's an important
story that everybody else is talking
about whistleblowers and impeachment but
I to me this is the thing we need to
focus on Mattel is is Mattel is
releasing gender-neutral dolls and time
has a whole story about it they're very
excited about it I want to read a bit
just just a little bit of it to you
because it's funny but also because
there's a point I want to make here at
the end of this okay so this is
mattel on the gener neutrals says a
child opens a box he starts jumping and
screaming with joy not an unusual sound
in the halls of Mattel's headquarters
where researchers test new toys but this
particular toy is a doll and it's rare
for parents to bring boys into these
research groups to play with dolls it's
rarer still for a boy to immediately
attach himself to one the way that Shia
just did an eight-year-old who considers
himself gender fluid and whose favorite
color is black one wink peep paint the
next Shia sometimes plays with his
younger sisters dolls at home but their
girlie princess stuff he says
dismissively I'm gonna stop here for a
minute and I'm gonna sound like a broken
record but in eight-year-old who
considers himself gender fluid that
sentence means nothing it means nothing
first of all because the phrase gender
fluid means nothing gender is not a
there is no gender fluid
despite will work what we are told
gender is a is an objective thing it's
not a it's not it's not a fluid it's not
a spectrum but even aside from that even
if gender fluid did mean something in
eight-year-old who considers himself
that he has no idea what gender fluid
means well nobody does because doesn't
mean anything but he has very little
clue what it even means to be a boy or
girl he doesn't really even know what
that means if you asked this
eight-year-old child to define what is a
boy he would probably have a difficult
time giving you especially a scientific
definition yet somehow he's decided that
he doesn't quite identify as that also
do you think it's a coincidence that his
name is a Shia that's SH I ' a and he
identifies as Jennifer so so he has this
kind of ambiguous name and then he ends
up identifying as an ambiguous child
what a coincidence
that's not a self-fulfilling prophecy at
all it says this doll with its
prepubescent body and childish features
looks more like him right down to the
wave of bleached blonde bangs the hair
is just like mine Shia says swing his
head in tandem with the dolls then he
turns to the playmate in the toy testing
room a seven-year-old girl named Jace
and asks should I put on the girl hand
the girl hair Shia fits a long blonde
wig on the dolls head and suddenly it is
no longer an avatar for him but for his
sister and then it goes on from there
very lovely story here's what the dolls
look like by the way let me show you
what they look like
so those are the dolls I only really
have one point I want to make here have
you noticed that ironically and these
dolls capture it ironically gender fluid
non-binary people they all end up
looking kind of the same with same style
and everything people identify this way
so they can distinguish themselves and
express themselves and be individuals
but then they end up looking
indistinguishable from everybody else
who's trying to be an individual it's
like when I was a kid some people wanted
to be different and unique so they
became goth that was the thing back when
I was a kid wasn't gender neutral or
gender fluid it's the same basic idea
where it's just people who want I don't
want to fit in with a crowd I want to be
different but then the big joke with the
goth kids is they all looked exactly the
same they were wearing a basically a
uniform and that's what's funny because
if I said to you if I said to you
picture a girl just picture a girl in
your head not any specific girl right
not someone you know but just a girl you
might have a general image in your mind
of what a girl basically looks like but
a girl could look like so many different
things you're not you're not gonna be
able to get very specific when you think
about what a girl looks like again you
have just a general idea but within
those general parameters a girl could
look like many different things could be
a wide diversity of what a girl looks
like because there isn't really a girl
uniform
but I said do you picture someone who
identifies as gender-fluid
you immediately have in your mind an
exact image of this person down to the
hairstyle down to everything because
gender-fluid is ironically a very rigid
specific kind of thing in in their
effort to be different and to be unique
they end up looking like everyone else
who's making the same ever and that's
because actually as it turns out you
know there there isn't anything
constricting or rigid about just being a
boy or girl there's a lot of leeway in
within those parameters to express
yourself however you want but then when
you try to leave those when you want to
be such an individual that you leave
those parameters behind that's when you
end up in this very narrow box where you
look like everybody else in the box okay
I wanted to mention I wanted to mention
this too there was another another
hearing this is a couple of days ago not
related to whistleblowers or impeachment
or Trump at all so just a little change
of pace here but I had to I've got to
play this for you because it's so weird
and also funny it was a it was a hearing
on the dangers of e-cigarettes as we
have talked about there's there is a an
effort now and this is one this is is
why I always say by when you hear
bipartisan when something is bipartisan
that's when you should really be worried
whereas the media always tells all we
need bipartisan agreement no actually
that's that's what it's really bad if
both sides are agreeing on something now
you got to run for the hills because you
know it's something really stupid these
cigarette thing is a good example this
this idea of banning e-cigarettes or
certain flavors of them Trump likes the
idea Democrats are on the same page look
if the Democrats and Trump can agree
then you know it must be a really really
bad idea
so they were doing a hearing on it and
this is just to show you this is one
thing that's very frustrating for people
who and I don't I don't smoke your
cigarettes myself
I guess smoke isn't even really the
right term but I don't use e-cigarettes
it's a similar thing when we talk about
marijuana the the people who do use
these cigarettes or you know marijuana
they always get frustrated because it
seems to them that the people who are
opposed to it and want to ban it have no
idea what they're talking about and
don't know anything about it and yet
they want to ban it and I think those
people who are frustrated have reason to
be frustrated and we'll see why here in
a second Rashidah Talib she was one of
the representatives involved in this
house Oversight and Reform subcommittee
and first I'll play this clip for you
because this was just weird this was
just a weird a weird moment from Talib
watch this you call yourself a converted
conservative and a reformed Marxist are
you conspiracy theorist I think my
politics are entirely irrelevant to this
hearing oh okay why were you winking at
one of my colleagues on the other side
of the aisle you winked because I know
Glenn Grothman oh that's what so the
winking did he introduce me he's a
friend of mine okay understand I didn't
know what the winking was because I
thought maybe there was something like a
conspiracy thing going on there I didn't
do you think there's a conspiracy in
this story ma'am no I actually think
people are speaking truth here and you
can provide information may I add rap
may I address the truth well the truth
to you is very different for the
majority of people in this room who do
believe that children are for me as I
quit smoking with these cigarettes
encoded 8 million other people you're
still smoking I'm not smoking thank you
thank you I'm not lying under oath order
please
and then ok so that that that's very
strange but here's the part and this is
where it gets frustrating for let's say
people who do vape because here's the
part where Talib makes a claim
scientific claim this is the party of
science but makes a very anti scientific
scientific claim watch this you know I
go in to speak to kids all the time
you know do the 3rd 2nd grade and 3rd
grade reading cause they always ask well
what do you do you know and I tell them
I work at the Capitol and I show them
the picture and tell them where it is
geography wise and then I tell them you
know when I was your age I used to go to
restaurants with my my parents and they
say you know right now you go and they
say how many people in your group when I
was little they said non smoking or
smoking section and the kids are like
what and I was like yeah they would say
non smoking smoke because they smoked in
cigarettes in public places like
restaurants hospitals schools planes and
the kids eyes are wide like Wyatt
that's unbelievable and I said yes even
though scientist people were saying
secondhand smoking was worse was worse
than directly smoking cigarettes and
even though health experts and others
were coming forward you had big industry
corporate greed misleading information
out there to the public what the real
real impact was on health and so it's so
important that you all continue to speak
truth she says scientists say that
secondhand smoke is worse than directly
smoking that is not true
scientists do not say that at least no
credible scientists do that is that is
absolutely not true
ok the the it doesn't even make any
sense how could how could secondhand
smoke be worse than directly smoking
cigarettes but when you smoke you are
inhaling directly from the cigarette
you're also inhaling the secondary smoke
to as the person who is smoking you are
going to be closer to the secondary I
mean unless unless maybe if you're if
you're smoking you've got someone tied
down there like onto a chair and then
you're directly smoking in his face just
blowing it right into his face maybe
then but but in a normal circumstance if
you're smoking you're inhaling directly
from the cigarette you're but the smoke
that comes out you're also inhaling that
too because that's in the air around you
so what to leave is claiming is that
it's worse to only inhale some of the
secondary smoke than it is to inhale all
of the direct smoke
and most of the secondary smoke does
that make any sense now is secondhand
smoke good for you okay it's not good I
don't think anyone's gonna claim that
it's a health benefit I don't think
there's any studies showing that it's
gonna it's gonna help you health-wise it
is though it is an open question whether
or not second secondary smoke or
secondhand smoke has any significant
health you know it has any significant
negative impact on your health for for
people who are you know now if you have
asthma emphysema something like that
bronchitis then obviously being around
secondhand smokes a different matter but
if you're a basically healthy person the
jury is kind of out on what kind of
impact secondhand smoke is going to have
on you especially in a casual
environment now if you're in the
enclosed space with somebody smoking
constantly for years at a time then
again that's gonna be different from
someone who's sort of casually around it
but the the link between secondhand
smoke and cancer that there have been
some studies that found a link there
have also been studies that that have
said that there's no link there's no
discernible link but putting all that to
the side this claim here is completely
ridiculous it is not true and this again
is exactly what is frustrating when when
you're someone who enjoys using a
certain product whether it's cigarettes
or regular cigarettes or marijuana or
whatever alcohol you've got other people
advocating a ban on it and then you
notice that the or how about guns griggs
but maybe the number one example of what
I'm talking about here we're famously
the Democrats who are the gun grabbers
when they get to talking about guns you
discover you realize very quickly if no
idea what they're talking about they've
never used they've never probably even
held a gun before they don't even know
the difference between the different
types of firearms if no clue what
they're talking about and yet they want
to ban it
it would seem it would behoove you it's
your responsibility at a minimum if
you're gonna advocate for banning
something at least learn what it is
first and what it
surely does so that that goes from being
funny to then when you think about it
actually just takes you off all right I
have one more thing I need to discuss
before we get to emails and I saved this
for last even though it's probably the
most important issue of the day I don't
make a habit of attacking my co-workers
in public
mostly I attack them in private but one
of my daily wire colleagues last night
lashed out with the most bigoted attack
I've ever seen and it was something that
well Amanda presto Giacomo she's if you
if you read the site you know the name
she writes a lot of the article she gets
approximately ninety five trillion hits
a day on her articles I think and and I
like her stuff generally but this tweet
crossed the line essentially it amounts
to her coming out as a Nazi it's
basically what it is so I want you to
take a look at this here's the tweet and
like I said I I'm very sorry that I need
to publicly denounce someone who works
for the same company but what choice do
I have
she says this is a really weird pet
peeve of mine and it's probably crazy
but I really dislike men who are not on
the beach wearing flip-flops what if a
woman has a flat tire and you have to
help but if there's some sort of
altercation you can't react in
flip-flops now underneath this
outlandish prejudiced discriminatory
screed there are a bunch of women much
of women agreeing you know somehow and
insisting that as men we should forfeit
our First Amendment rights to wear
flip-flops including I should add a
least uh key a former colleague of mine
at the blaze and this I'm just going
after everybody now but what am I gonna
do
generally her stuff also is good but she
and look at this you aren't gonna
believe it she says she says no one
needs to see man toes apparently Ali
hasn't learned doesn't realize that body
shaming is
illegal in the United States now I need
to speak up here because sandal shaming
has become one of the great crises of
our time men like myself who wear
sandals especially flip-flops we are
subjected to harassment abuse murder yes
men are murdered routinely
for wearing flip-flops
Masoli time and it has to end uh I'm not
gonna be ashamed of my sandals I won't
be ashamed of my feet my feet which are
elegant and beautiful and if I wear
socks with my sandals which I do it is
not because I'm ashamed of my feet it is
because I am proud of my socks okay this
whole notion that sandals are unmanly is
absurd unmanly do your research read a
history book history of sandals pick it
up that's a real book I think you know
who wore sandals the Vikings the Vikings
were unmanly really you think the
Vikings couldn't change a tire they
probably couldn't as they weren't
familiar with the technology but I mean
you get my point
guess who else wore sandals Alexander
the Great Gandalf William Wallace
Aristotle Socrates okay
all of them sandal wears but cher yeah I
guess it would have been better if they
all were never born according to Amanda
as I what you want you say that they
should have been born at all that's what
you said that's a direct quote so how
about this I'm gonna I'm gonna end this
debate right here and then we're gonna
move on but let me I want you to I'm
gonna show you something look at this
photograph okay you see this who is that
who's in that photograph right there
that's just someone named Jesus Christ
that's all of Nazareth although by this
picture you'd think maybe he was from
Minnesota because he's pretty pretty
white he's maybe a lot whiter than you
thought he would be given that he's a
middle-eastern man but that's not the
point the point I want you to zoom in
let's zoom in now
now water on his feet you tell me what
are on Jesus's feet sandals flip-flops
no less and what is he doing in sandals
oh nothing but just walking on water so
I want you to think about that anyone
out there next time you think of shaming
a man for his flip-flops think about
that WWJD that's all all right we'll go
to emails Matt well show at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com this one
from Lenny I just I love this email
because it's a pretty hilarious
backhanded compliment and that's why I'm
gonna read it says Matt I have to
confess that I hated your show at first
I thought it was preachy and boring and
you seemed completely humorless I really
wish that you would be fired for a long
time but I came back to your show a few
months ago and either you've changed
completely or I have now I find you
hilarious and very interesting you're my
favorite show of the day Lee Weyer now
the one I make sure to listen to every
day maybe I misjudged you I still think
you're kind of a jerk and you get overly
emotional about things sometimes and
seem to ramble too much at points but
that's part of your charm
I'm now a huge fan though there's a
there isn't another show out there quite
like yours and I love it
that there was just so much insulting
and complimenting packed into one
paragraph there and I really appreciate
that it's a it's a little bit wildering
I'm not sure well you know that's one of
those things where someone says that and
your first reaction is what like oh okay
thanks and then but then when you leave
you're you're thinking hold on a second
was that am I should I be happy now or
what let's see here this is from Maggie
says Matt your comments on Twitter about
push presents were very dangerous for
your health
my recommendation get your wife a push
present don't ask questions
yes oh my my wife what she's our
everything my wife recently brought up
this thing called push presence I don't
know have you heard of push push push
president well I had to google it and my
wife is pregnant by the way that's an
important part of this story but a push
present is apparently presence that
evident
the husband is supposed to buy for the
wife as the congratulations I guess for
the fact that she gave birth here's my
point and this is what maggie is
referencing and really this should be
uncontroversial but I think that the man
should be receiving the push present
because I think you could argue and I
try to explain this to my wife you could
argue that pregnancy is harder on the
man than it is on the woman now yes
she's the one who has the physical side
effects to wrestle with but I think you
know the the the emotional toll on the
man having to deal with I mean not deal
with deal will but but but listen all
I'm saying is that sometimes it can tend
to be you know trying
well not trying I don't mean trying but
but you know women when they're pregnant
can be difficult not difficult but you
get you so anyway I hope my wife doesn't
watch this show let's move on from Aaron
says hi Matt a few times now I've heard
you almost flirt with the lie of
evolution you've never come out and
explicitly said that you believe in it
I'm wondering if you have the guts to do
that if you really do believe it I'm
sure you must recognize that evolution
is called a theory for a reason
it's just a guess made by scientists
with an agenda they want to think we are
descended from chimps because they want
us to live in a godless world I hope
that you have not been deceived but I'm
afraid based on your comments that you
have hello Aaron first of all and thanks
for for bringing this up actually
because I think it's a really
interesting subject but first of all
don't accuse me of flirting with
evolution I'm married I would never do
that
second you asked me if I believe in it
well evolution is not a religious
doctrine I don't know if believe in it
is really the best phrasing III get what
you're saying I just that phrasing seems
weird to me do I think that the evidence
overwhelmingly points in its direction
yes because
does it simply does that's that's all
and I I think any honest reading of the
science behind it will lead you to that
conclusion now let me try to clear up a
few things here because these are common
misconceptions and there's a there's a
few things you said in your email that
are factually incorrect and so I want to
clear those up because I really believe
that there are a significant number of
Christians in America who either flat
out reject evolution or are skeptical
about it I think maybe for a lot of them
if if they understood what the theory
really isn't I don't mean this as an
insult I think that a lot of people they
really don't know what it is they don't
really understand what the claim is
and and that's what I notice anyway when
I talk to people about it because they
say things that are well no that's not
evolution okay so for instance you say
it's just a theory which is like a guess
what that's wrong it's incorrect
it's a popular misconception again but
theory in a scientific sense is not a
guess that's not what's meant by the
word it's not how you define scientific
theory it's not a hypothesis here either
hey pop a hypothesis hypothesis is a is
a separate thing it leads up to a theory
you know so I might begin with the
hypothesis but a theory in science
here's what it means it means something
that is explanatory it is a tested
verified explanation for what we observe
in nature that's what a theory is so I
can't stress this enough the phrase just
a scientific theory is absurd it's it's
what you're saying is well it's just a
tested and verified explanation the just
in that sentence seems kind of out of
place you know now why do you think we
still speak of the germ theory of
disease or the theory of relativity or
the heliocentric theory or the theory of
gravity does that mean that gravity
germs and the Earth's orbit are all
guesses they aren't facts we don't know
No there they are facts it is a fact
that the Earth orbits around the Sun it
is a fact that germs cause disease it is
a fact that you know gravity is a fact
but they are explanatory facts and
that's why we call them theories
okay now evolution here's why it's a
theory which is to say here's how it has
risen to that lofty level of being a
scientific theory because Darwin came up
with a workable model to explain the
diversity of life on Earth and and a
workable testable model and that's
that's how real science works and I know
the word science is thrown around a lot
these days and there are people claiming
things that are science that aren't we
just gave an example of that with
Rashidah to leave but if it's real
science that means it's it's it's
testable you can go and test it if you
don't have to take anyone's word for it
you know what to take it on faith you
can go and look at it test it ever since
he postulated the theory of evolution
subsequent discoveries have consistently
confirmed it while nothing has
disconfirmed it so I'll say that again
every relevant discovery every relevant
discovery since that theory has had the
effect of confirming it there has not
been one relevant discovery to have a
significant disconfirming effect so his
theory had predictive power which is how
you know what's good
keep in mind Darwin he came up he came
out with the Origin of Species it wasn't
yet known that the earth is four billion
years old we which it is by the way well
it's it's it's certainly several billion
years old we know that and he didn't
know about genetics either Mendel was
was working on that sort of he was
working on that sort of parallel to
Darwin but they weren't working together
on it yet
in order for Darwin's idea to work the
earth would need to be billions of years
old
and there would need to be some kind of
mechanism whereby our traits you know
are passed down through the generations
and what do you know subsequent
discoveries in geology genetics as well
as archaeology paleontology chemistry
cosmology really every field of study
have confirmed that they've all lined up
perfectly with with what with what was
originally proposed so so that's really
powerful you know it really is it's it's
it's just like the scientists it's like
the scientists who were able to it's
like the scientists who came up based
based on mathematical equations you had
scientists who came up with that this
idea that black holes must exist
somewhere in the universe and then what
do you know a few months ago we actually
found one so that's a really good theory
when you when you come up with you will
you say okay if I'm right about this
we're gonna discover XYZ and then we do
discover XYZ well that is very powerful
that is a very very strong indication
that the original idea was largely
correct I focus on genetics because
that's really where it said people get
caught up on fossils and everything the
fossils really almost don't matter the
fossils do confirm evolution this stuff
about how there's a missing link and we
haven't found that it's that's not true
that's false we do have the fossils we
have the links but the vast majority I
mean the vast vast vast vast majority of
life-forms that have ever existed on
earth are not going to fossilize because
you need a certain specific condition
for fossilization to occur most
life-forms will not fossilize and the
the the small small minority that do
fossilize the vast majority of those
will never be found so what that tells
you is that you know fossils are
important but you can only learn so much
from that because the sample size is
going to be so small and that's why
genetics is so important this to me
this this is the whole thing according
to duck Darwin what he said long before
anyone could actually confirm this but
he said that we are most closely related
to chimpanzees and then further down the
family tree would be mice and dogs and
things like that and then further away
would be fish and-and-and and other life
lower
forms and and and by the way let me
Rebecca because you had a nut you had
another mistake and what you said you
said that you know descended from chimps
that's that's not the theory of let's
not know that's not what that's not how
the theory goes nobody thinks were
descended from chimps any more than you
are descended from your cousin and this
is why when people say oh well if we're
really descended from chimps that how
how do chimps still exist that's like
saying if you really if I'm really
descended from my grandfather then how
does my cousin exist it doesn't make any
sense
the idea is that seven million years ago
we shared a common ancestor it's not
it's not a direct line like we are like
you know your your great-grandfather was
a chimpanzee it's we share a common
ancestor a long time ago that's what the
theory says okay so and that's and
that's what Darwin proposed well finally
a century later when we could look at
the human genome we found that what do
you know we shared 99% of our DNA with
chimps a little bit less with mice far
less with fish and on and on down the
line okay what is that a coincidence
yeah I think genetics just puts to rest
any reasonable doubt on this subject
because we could look at our genes and
we can see the familiar relationships
so either Darwin was basically right
although he wasn't right about
everything he said obviously but he was
basically right or or God is trying to
trick us God is playing a fun little
trick by making our DNA exactly match
what the evolutionary theory predicts
what to you seems more likely this again
genetics this is a testable workable
thing we know that it works scientists
can go into a laboratory they can look
at your genes and they can tell you who
you're related to and they will be right
because you can establish relations
through genetics and it's by that same
system in that same field of study where
they can establish relations between the
species which is exactly what you would
expect if Darwin was right and it's
exactly what you would not
expect if Darwin was wrong if Darwin was
wrong then when we were finally able to
look at the human genome we should have
discovered that there is no similarity
at all between us in chimpanzees that's
what we should have discovered if he was
wrong but we discovered the opposite and
there have been many many many other
confirmations of evolutionary theory
over the last many decades you know one
of them is that we have seen it happen
we have watched it happen we have
observed evolution happening in real
time
for example certain species of moths
during the industrial revolution over
the last 100 200 years have turned
darker ok why is that because well
because darker blends in more with the
environment now living in a concrete
jungle with air pollution and everything
else
how does that happen natural selection
and this was really Darwin's innovation
evolutionary theory predates him natural
selection was his thing actually there
was someone else who at the same time
came up with a similar idea but but in
any case natural selection is very
simple genetic genetic mutations produce
different traits in living things that's
there's nothing theoretical about that
we know that right you would agree yet
the genetic mutations and they produce
different traits ok agreed right we all
agree ok now those genetic traits are
passed down through the generations
through reproduction you would agree
correct that's no I mean no one
disagrees with that ok great
some traits are going to be advantageous
for survival and some won't be the the
the creatures that have those
advantageous traits are more likely to
survive thus are more likely to
reproduce and so those traits are going
to pass down while the traits that are
not advantageous for survival are going
to die off because the people with those
whatever creature we're talking about
whether it's moths or people or whatever
are going to die off so that's that's
the whole
that's that's it and in a hundred years
or 200 years it can produce mild changes
like a moth changing color so no one
thinks that it's it's you know we you
hear this this this analogy sometimes
where evolution is like it's like
claiming that you know if you if you
took a bunch of pieces of metal and
jumbled them together you'd end up with
a with a Boeing 747 that's that's not
what evolutionary theory of course
that's absurd that wouldn't happen right
it's not what it says it just says it's
descent with modification it's it's the
you have certain traits advantageous for
survival those those are going to live
on while the ones that are not
advantageous die off and then over time
you have gradual changes in a hundred
years we can see a moth change color
we've seen that in a hundred million
years so a million times longer the
changes will be more significant that
makes a lot of sense doesn't it so
what's the issue here it's perfectly
sensible confirmed by science observable
testable logical no problem this is know
and and you know you you can that's why
I would just if people just understood
what it actually is I I think a lot of
this controversy would would go away and
and when I say study it you know to go
on google and type in how to debunk
evolution or whatever you know and we
all study things that way I think a lot
of us when we claim that we research
something that's really what we did
where we had we had our conclusion
already in mind based on our
preconceived notions and then we look
specifically for talking points on the
internet that would help us support that
conclusion
that's not research that's not what
research is you got to look you have to
look at the whole context of something
and you have to try to find sources that
do not appear to be propaganda that
don't have clear biases everybody has a
bias but if there's a clear bias
a clear vested interest in a certain
conclusion you got to stay away from
those sources as much as possible and
and at the very least read both sides so
with evolution don't just read some
debunking website without actually going
to the scientists themselves and seeing
what they read a whole book written by a
scientist explaining what evolution is a
lot of books out there like this read it
yourself don't have someone else tell
you what's wrong with it read it
yourself read the whole book the whole
thing just one book I challenge you to
that Aaron I challenge you find a book
explaining evolution not written by
someone who's a skeptic debunking it
giving you talking about but a whole
book explaining what it is read the
whole book that's it that's my whole
challenge
now how does this affect things
theologically well not at all as far as
I can tell
God has obviously chosen to create
things in a gradual way so what that's
fine God guides the formation and
development of life and he does it
gradually I I I see no issue there I see
no problem with it does that mean that
we can't interpret the the you know the
genesis 100% literally yeah it does but
again so what some things in the Bible
are not literal the Bible talks about
the Sun moving in the sky around the
earth that's what the Bible talks about
now
we know that that is not literally true
the earth moves around the Sun not the
other way around a lot of people for
hundreds for many centuries a lot of
people thought that those verses that
seem to indicate a heliocentric model of
the universe thought that those verses
were literal and that's what got Galileo
in trouble but he came along and said
that no and so a lot of people did what
I think some Christians are doing today
where they're saying no I there's no way
to interpret this metaphorically it's
it's it's got to be literal and so
therefore I insist that the Sun moves
around the earth well eventually you
just can't it's it's a fact
I mean heliocentrism is a fact you can't
get around it and so Christians were
prompted at that point to go back and
realize that they had misinterpreted the
verses that they thought were literal
apparently were not exactly and that's
fine and my point is simply that you
can't really take this high-and-mighty
pose of well no I take God at His Word I
think we should take God at His Word -
the question is what is he trying to say
we know the Bible is a book with many
different genres saying and doing many
different things it's not one book
written by one person and with with
every page in every chapter and every
book within it trying to do and
communicate and say the exact same thing
that's not the case yet dozens of
authors over a thousand years doing and
saying different things the question is
what what exact how do you interpret it
and that's that is that's one of the
questions with with theology and
exegesis but you can't take this high in
my tipos about no I refuse to take any
of this metaphorically you do take it
metaphors a lot of it you do take this
stuff metaphor if this if we were having
this conversation 600 years ago you
would be insisting that the that the Sun
goes around the earth and you would be
saying that for me to claim otherwise is
to call God a liar but now you accept
what was once a a theological
controversy you accept is there's really
only one side to it here's the cost of
taking it literally fine you can read
justice literally but then how do you
read human DNA you know God wrote that
too didn't he in fact he wrote that more
directly okay we don't believe that God
literally reached down with his hand out
of the sky and wrote the Bible
physically okay you inspired the the
biblical authors DNA though he does
direct he wrote DNA and it is a quite a
complex
fascinating beautiful code well if
Genesis is literal than human DNA which
clearly points to familial relationships
between species is a bit of trickery on
the part of God God is fooling us you
know God knowing that the evolutionary
theory would one day be one day be
formulated knowing that knowing that
after the formulation of that theory we
would be able to look at human DNA and
draw these conclusions knowing all that
God's still making it seem as if we are
related in some way to chimpanzees that
to me seems like you're close it seems
like you're calling God a liar there
you're telling us he's lying to us
through the through the through our
genetic code or what testing our faith
what kind of test is that the test is
don't believe your lying eyes the test
is don't follow the evidence what is the
lesson from God don't look at the DNA
you've gone too far I didn't want you to
know about this I mean it just gets
ridiculous I think there's no problem
with the DNA says what is genetics
points where it points and and and
that's it and and and God is telling us
something and we can believe what God is
telling us God a telling is telling us
something through Genesis as well I'm
just suggesting that maybe Aaron you're
a little bit wrong about what God is
telling us maybe you might have
misinterpreted it it is possible so you
can
to me and say oh you're saying God is is
yeah I'm not I'm not talking about God
I'm talking about you I'm saying that
maybe you have misinterpreted all right
but I I do appreciate the I really do
appreciate bringing that up cuz I think
it's a really interesting subject I find
it fascinating you know and I really
love to learn about the physical world
and and and how life developed and and
and all that I just find it so
interesting and I think that Christians
should not shy away from that I think we
should embrace this because it's amazing
and fascinating and beautiful and and
there's nothing to be afraid of
alright we will leave it there and I
thank everybody for watching and
listening today
Godspeed oh the Matt Walsh show is
produced by Robert Sterling associate
producer alexia Garcia Del Rio executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there
[Music]